The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back to 6046.
AUDIENCE: Woohoo.
PROFESSOR: Are you guys ready
to learn an awesome data
structure?
AUDIENCE: Woohoo.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's do it.
This is a data structure named
after a human being, Peter van
Emde Boas.
I was just corresponding
with him yesterday.
And he, in the '70s, he
invented this really cool data
structure.
Its super fast It's amazing.
It's actually pretty
simple to implement.
And it's used a lot, in
practice, in network routers,
among other things.
And we're going
to cover it today.
So let me first tell
you what it does.
So it's an old data structure.
But I feel like it's taken us
decades to really understand.
Question.
AUDIENCE: You're mic's not on.
PROFESSOR: In what sense?
It's not amplified.
It's just for the cameras.
So it's taken us
decades, really,
to understand this data
structure, exactly how it works
and why it's useful.
The problem it's solving is what
you might call a predecessor
problem.
It's very similar to
the sort of problem
that binary search trees solve.
But we're going to do it faster,
but in a somewhat different
model, in that the elements
we're going to be storing
are not just things that
we know how to compare.
That would be the
comparison model.
We're storing integers.
And the integers come from a
universe, U, of size little u.
And we'll assume that they're
non-negative, so from 0
to u minus 1.
Although you could
support negative
integers without
much more effort.
And the operations
we want to support,
we're storing a set of
n of those elements.
We want to do insert,
delete, and successor.
So these are operations you
should be familiar with.
You should know
how to solve these
in log n time per operation with
a balanced binary search tree,
like AVL trees.
You want to add something
to the set, delete something
from the set, or
given a value I want
to know the next largest
value that is in the set.
So if you draw that as
a one dimensional thing,
you've got some items
which are in your set.
And then, you have a query.
So you ask for the
successor of this value.
Then you're asking for, what
is the next value that's
in the set?
So you want to return this item.
OK, predecessor would
be the symmetric thing.
But if you could
solve successor,
you could usually
solve predecessor.
So we'll focus on
these three operations,
although, in the
textbook, you'll
see there are lots
of operations you
could do with van Emde Boas.
So far so good.
We know how to do
this in log n time.
We are going to do
it in log log u time.
Woah, amazing.
So an extra log, but we're
cheating a little bit, in that
we're replacing n with u.
Now in a lot of applications,
u is pretty reasonable,
like 2 to the 32 or 2
to the 64, depending
on what kind of integers
you usually work with.
So log log of that is usually
really tiny, and often smaller
than log n.
So in particular,
on the theory side,
for example, if u is
a polynomial in n,
or even larger than that, you
can support n to the polylog n.
Then log log u is
the same as log log
n, up to constant factors.
And so this is an
exponential improvement
over regular balanced
binary search trees.
OK, so super fast, and it's
also pretty clean and simple,
though it'll take us a
little while to get there.
One application for
this, as I mentioned,
is in network routers.
And I believe most network
routers use the van Emde Boas
data structure these
days, though just
changed in the
last decade or so.
Network router, you have to
store a routing table, which
looks like, for IP
range from this to this,
please send your
packets along this port.
For IP range from this to
this, send along this port.
So if you mark the
beginnings of those ranges
as items in your set, and
given an actual IP address,
you want to know
what range it's in,
that is a predecessor
or a successor problem.
And so van Emde Boas lets
you solve that really fast.
u, for IPV4 is only
is only 2 to the 32.
So that's super
fast and practical.
It's going to take
like five operations
to do log log 2 to the 32.
So that's it.
And as you may know,
network routers
are basically computers.
And so they used to have a
lot of specialized hardware.
These days it's pretty
general purpose.
And so you want nice data
structures, like the one
we'll cover.
OK, so we want to
shoot for log log u.
We're going to get there
by a series of improvements
on a very simple idea.
This is not the original
way that van Emde Boas
got to this concept.
But it's sort of the
modern take on it.
It's one that's in the textbook.
So the first question is, how
might we get a log log u bound?
Where might that come from?
That's a question for you.
This is just intuition.
Any suggestions?
We see logs all the time.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You organize the
height of a tree into a tree.
PROFESSOR: Ah, good.
You organize the height
of the tree into a tree.
So we normally think of a tree,
let's say we have u down here.
So the height is log u.
So somehow, we want
a binary search
on the levels of this tree.
Right, if we could kind of
start in the middle level,
and then decide whether
we need to go up or down,
I'm totally unclear
what that would mean.
But in fact, that's exactly
the van Emde Boas will do.
So you can binary
search-- I think
we won't see that until the very
end-- but on levels of a tree.
So at least some intuition.
Now let's think about this
in terms of recurrences.
There's a recurrence for
binary search, which is usually
you have k things, t of k is
t of k over 2 plus order 1.
You spend constant
time to decide
whether you should go left
or right in a binary search,
or in this case up
and down somehow.
And then you reduce to a
problem of half the size.
So this solves to log k.
In our case, k is
actually log u.
So we want a recurrence that
looks something like t of log u
equals t of log
u/2 plus order 1.
OK, even if you don't believe in
the binary search perspective,
this is clearly a recurrence
that solves to log log u.
I'm just substituting
k equals log u here.
So that could be
on the right track.
Now, that's in terms of log u.
What if I wanted to rewrite
this recurrence in terms u?
What would I get?
If I wanted to have this
still solve to log log u,
what should I write here?
If I change the logarithm of
a number by a factor of 2,
how does u change?
AUDIENCE: Square root.
PROFESSOR: Square root.
OK, So I've changed what
the variable is here.
But this is really
the same recurrence.
It will still
solve to log log u.
The number of times you have to
apply square root to a number
to get to 1 is log log u.
So this is some more intuition
for how van Emde Boas is
going to achieve log log u.
And in fact, this is the primary
intuition we'll be using.
So what we would like is
to some take our problem,
which has size u, and
split it into problems
of size square root
of u, so that we only
have to recurse on one of them.
And then, we'll get
this recurrence.
OK, that's where
we're going to go.
But we're going to start with
a very simple data structure
for representing a set of n
numbers from the universe 0
up to u minus 1.
And let's say, initially, our
goal is for insert and delete
to be constant time.
But let's not worry
about successor.
Successor could
take linear time.
What would be a good data
structure for storing items
in this universe?
I want u to be involved somehow.
I don't just want
to, like, store them
in a linked list of items
or assorted array of items.
I would like u to
be involved, insert
and delete constant time.
Very simple.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Simply an array.
PROFESSOR: In an array, yeah.
What's the array indexed by?
AUDIENCE: It would be index n.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: By the index of n.
PROFESSOR: The
index of n, close.
AUDIENCE: The value.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: The value, yeah.
Good.
So I want-- this is normally
called a bit vector, where
I want array of size u, and
for each cell in the array,
I'm going to write 0 or 1.
0 means absent.
1 means present.
It's in the set.
So let me draw a
picture, maybe over here.
Let me take my example
and give you a frisbee.
Let me put it in the middle.
So this is an example of a set
with-- if I maybe highlight
a little bit-- here's 1.
Here's a 1, and
a one, and a one.
So there are 4
elements in the set.
The universe size is 16.
n equals 4, in this
particular example.
If I want to insert into this
set, I just change 0 to a 1.
If I want to delete from the
set, I change a 1 to a 0.
So those are constant time.
Good.
If I want to do a successor
query, not so good.
I might need to
spend order u time.
Maybe I asked for the
successor of this item,
and the only thing
to do is just keep
jumping until I get to a 1.
And the worst case,
there's almost to u 0's
in a row, or u minus n.
So that's really slow.
But this, in fact, will
be our starting point.
It may seem really silly.
But it's actually a
good starting point
for van Emde Boas.
So the second idea is, we're
going to take our universe
and split it into clusters.
van Emde Boas, the person,
likes to call these galaxies.
I think that's a nice name
for pieces of the universe.
But textbook calls it clusters.
Because they used
to call it clusters.
So now, it's question of how
big the cluster should be.
But I gave you
this picture, and I
want to think about these
galaxies as separate chunks,
and I ask for the
successor of this,
how could I possibly speed
up the successor search?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could form a tree
for each cluster and connect--
PROFESSOR: You could form a tree
here and store what at the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Could store an
or between the two bits.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
I like this.
So I could store the
or of these two bits--
clean this up a little
bit-- or of these two bits,
or of these two bits, and so on.
The or is interesting, because
this 0 bit, in particular,
tells me there's
nothing in here.
So I should just be
able to skip over it.
So you're imagining a kind
of binary search-ish thing.
It's a good idea.
So each node here, I'm
just writing the or
of its two children.
And in fact, you could
do this all the way up.
You could build an
entire binary tree.
But remember, what
we're trying to do
is a binary search on
the levels of the tree.
And so, in particular, I'm
going to focus on this level.
This is the middle
level of that tree
if I drew out the whole thing.
And that level is interesting,
because it's just summarizing--
is there anybody in here, is
there anybody in this cluster,
is there anybody
in this cluster,
in this cluster.
So we call this
the summary vector.
So we'll come back to your
tree perspective at some point.
That is a good big picture
of what's going on.
But at this level, I'm
just going to say, well
let's store the bit vector.
Let's also store
this summary vector.
And now, when I want to find
the successor of something,
first I'll look
inside the cluster.
If I don't find my answer, I'll
go up to the summary vector
and find where is
the next cluster that
has something in it.
And then I'll go
into that cluster
and look for the first one.
OK, that's a good next step.
So this will split the
universe into clusters.
How big should the
clusters be to balance out?
There's three
searches I'm doing.
One is within a cluster.
One is in the summary vector.
And one is within
another cluster.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Square root u.
PROFESSOR: Square root u.
Yeah.
That will balance out.
If there's square
root of u size,
then the number of clusters
will be square root of u.
So the search in
the summary vector
will be the same as
the cost down here.
Also we know that
we kind of want
to do square root of
u recursion somehow.
So this is not yet
the recursive version.
But square root of
u is exactly right.
And I owe some frisbees, sorry.
Here's one frisbee.
And yeah, cool.
And I think also you one.
Sorry.
So clusters have
size square root
of u, the square
root of u of them.
And, cool.
So now, when I want to
do an insert or a delete,
it's still-- let's not
worry about delete.
That's a little tricky.
To do an insert,
it's still easy.
If I insert into
here, I set it to 1.
And I check, if this is already
0, I should also set that to 1.
Now deleting would be tricky.
To delete this guy and realize
that there's nothing else, eh.
Let's not worry about that
until we do a lot more work.
Let's just focus on
insert and successor.
So insert, with this strategy,
is still constant time.
It's two steps instead
of one, but it's good.
Successor does three things.
First, we look, let's
say, successor of x.
First thing we do is
look in x's cluster.
Then, if we don't find
what we're looking for,
then we'll look for the next
1 bit in the summary vector,
and then, we'll look for
the first 1 in that cluster.
So there are two cases.
In the lucky case, we find
the successor in the cluster
that we started in.
So that only takes root u time.
If we're unlucky, we
research in the summary.
That takes root u time.
And then we find
the first 1 bit.
That takes root u time.
Whole thing is square root of
u, which is, of course, not very
good, compared to log n.
But it's a lot
better than u, which
is our first method,
the bit vector.
So we've improved from
u to square root of u.
Now of course, the
idea is to recurse.
Instead of just doing a bit
vector at each of these levels,
we're going to
recursively represent each
of these clusters in this way.
This is where things get a
little magical, in the magic
of divide and conquer.
And then, we'll get
t of square root of u
instead of square root of u.
And then we'll get
a log log cost.
So before I get
there, let me give you
a little bit of
terminology and an example
for dealing with clusters.
OK, in general,
remember the things
we're searching for
are just integers.
And what we're talking
about is essentially
dividing an integer, like
x, by square root of u.
And so this is,
whatever, the quotient.
And this is the remainder.
So I want j to be
between 0 and strictly
less than square root of u.
Then this is unique, fundamental
theorem of arithmetic,
or something.
And i is the cluster number.
And then j is the position
of x within that cluster.
So let's do an example
like x equals 9.
So I didn't number
them over here.
This is x equals 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9-- here's the guy I'm
interested in-- 10,
11, 12, and so on.
So 9 is here.
This is cluster number 0, 1, 2.
So I claim 9 equals 2
times square root of u.
Here is 4.
I conveniently chose u
to be a perfect square.
And it is item 0,1
within the cluster.
And indeed, 9 equals
2 times 4 plus 1.
So in general, if
you're given x,
and I said, ah, look in x's
cluster, what that means
is look at x integer
divided by square root of u.
That's the cluster number.
And I'll try to search in there.
And I look in the
summary vector,
starting from that
cluster name, the name
of the cluster for this guy,
finding the next cluster.
Then I'll multiply
by square root of u
to get here, and
then continue on.
In general, because
dividing to multiplying-- I
don't want to have to
think about it too hard.
I'm going to say, define
some functions to make
this a little easier,
more intuitive.
So when I do integer division
by square root of u, which
is like taking the floor,
I'll call that high
of x, the high part of x.
And low of x is going
to be the remainder.
That's the j up here.
And if I have the high and
the low part, the i and the j,
I'm going to use
index to go back to x.
So index of ij is going to be i
times square root of u plus j.
Now why do I call
these high and low?
I'll give you a hint.
Here's the binary
representation of x.
In this case, high of x is 2.
And low of x is 1.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the high x
corresponds to the first two,
which is the first 2 bit.
And the low x corresponds
to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
High of x corresponds to
the high half of the bits.
And low of x corresponds to
the bottom half of the bits.
So these are the high order
bits and the low order bits.
And if you think
about it, remember
when we take square root of u
in logarithm, it takes log u
and divides it in half.
So it's exactly,
in the bit factor,
which is log u bits long,
we're dividing in half here,
and looking at the high
bits versus the low bits.
OK?
So that's another interpretation
of what this is doing.
And if you don't
like doing division,
as many computers don't like
to do, all we're actually doing
is masking out these
bits, or taking these bits
and shifting them over.
So these are very
efficient to actually do.
And maybe get some intuition
for why they're relevant.
So let's recurse, shall we?
I think now we know how this
splitting things up works.
So I'm going to call
the overall structure v,
or a van Emde Boas structure
I'm trying to represent is v.
And v is going to
consist of two parts.
One is an array of
all of the clusters.
I'm going to abbreviate
van Emde Boas as VEB.
And recursively, each
of those clusters
is going to be represented by a
smaller VEB structure, of size
square root of the given one.
OK, and i ranges from 0 to
square root of u minus 1.
OK, so there's square
root of u of them.
Total sizes is u.
And then, in
addition, we're going
to have a summary structure.
And this is also a size
square root of u VEB.
OK, you should think about
inserts and successors.
Those are the two operations
I care about for now.
Let's start with insert.
That's easier.
So if I want to insert an
item, x, into data structure v,
then first thing I
should do is insert
into its corresponding cluster.
So let's just get comfortable
with that notation.
We're inserting into the cluster
whose number is high of x.
That is where x belongs.
The name of its cluster
should be high of x.
And what we're going to
be inserting recursively
into there is low of x.
That is the name of x
local to that cluster.
x is a global name with
respect to v. This cluster only
represents a small range
of square root of u items.
So this gets us from
the big space of size u
to the small space
of size square root
of u within that cluster.
So that's basically what
high and low were made for.
But then, we have to also
update the summary structure.
So we need, just in case--
Maybe it's already there.
But in the worst case, it isn't.
So we'll just think of that
as recursively inserting
into v dot summary the
name of the cluster, which
is high of x.
High of x is keeping track of
which clusters are non-empty.
We've just inserted
something into this cluster.
So it's non-empty.
We better mark that
that cluster, high of x,
is non-empty in the
summary structure.
Why?
So we can do successor.
So let's move on to successor.
Actually, I want to mimic
the successor written here
on the bottom of the board.
So what we had in the
non-recursive version
was three steps.
So we're going to do
the same thing here.
We're going to look
within x's cluster.
We now know that is the
cluster known as high of x.
And either we find, and
we're happy, or we don't.
Then we're going to look at
v dot summary search for this
the successor of high of x.
Right, finding the next
1 bit, that is successor.
And then, I want to find the
first 1 bit in that cluster.
Is that a successor also?
Yeah.
That's just the successor
of negative infinity.
Finding the minimum element in a
cluster is the successor of -1,
or 0, or not zero.
But -1 would work, or
negative infinity, maybe more
intuitively.
That'll find the
smallest thing here.
So each of these is
a recursive call.
I can think of it as
recursively calling successor.
So let's do that.
I want to find the successor
of x in v. First thing
I'm going to do is
do the ij breakdown.
I'll let i be high of x and
j be-- I could do low of x.
But what I'm going to try for is
to search within this cluster,
high of x.
So I'm going to look for
the successor of cluster i,
which is cluster high
of x, of low of x.
OK, so that's this first step
of looking in x's cluster.
This is x's cluster.
This is x's name in the cluster.
I'm going to try to
find the successor.
But it might say infinity.
I didn't find anything.
And then I'll be unhappy
if j equals infinity.
So that's line one.
Well, then we're in
the wrong cluster.
High of x is not
the right cluster.
Let's find the
correct cluster, which
is going to be the
next non-empty cluster.
So I'm going to change i to be
the successor in the summary
structure of i.
So i was the name of a cluster.
It may have items in it.
But we want to find the
next non-empty thing.
Because we know the successor
we're looking for is not here.
OK.
So this is the cluster
we now belong in.
What item in the
cluster do we want?
Well, we want to find the
minimum item in that cluster.
And we're going to do that
by a recursive call, which
is j is the successor within
cluster i of minus infinity,
I'll say.
-1 would also work.
So this will find the
smallest item in the cluster.
And then, in both
cases, we get i and j,
which together in
this form describe
the value x that we care about.
So I'm just going to
say, return index of ij.
That's how we reconstruct an
item name for the structure v.
We knew which
substructure it's in.
And we know its name
within the substructure,
within the cluster.
Is this algorithm
clearly correct?
Good.
It's also really bad.
Well, it's better than
everything we've done so far.
The last result we had
was square root of u.
This is going to be better than
that, but still not log log u.
Why?
Both of these are bad.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You make more than
one call to [? your insert. ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
I make more than
one recursive call
to whatever the
operation is here.
Insert calls insert twice.
Here, successor calls successor
potentially three times.
This is a good challenge for me.
Let's see.
Eh, not bad.
Off by one.
OK, that's a common problem
in computer science, right?
Always off by one errors.
OK, so let's think of it
in terms of recurrences,
in case that's not clear.
Here we have t of u is 2
times t of square root of u.
Right, to solve a
problem of size u,
I solve two problems of size
square root of u plus constant.
Because high of x and
low of x, I'm assuming,
take constant time to do.
It's just, I have an integer.
I divide it in half.
Those are cheap.
What does this solve to?
It's probably easier to think
of it in terms of log u.
Then we could apply
the master method.
Right, this is the same
thing as t prime of log u
is 2 times t of log u
divided by 2 plus order 1.
This is not quite the
merge sort recurrence.
But it's not good.
One way to think
of it, is we start
with the total weight of log u.
We split into log over
2, but two copies of it.
So we're not saving anything.
And we didn't reduce
the problem strictly.
In terms of the recursion
tree, we have, you know,
log u-- well, it's hard
to think about because we
have constant total cost.
You could just plug this
in with the Master method,
or see that essentially
we're conserving mass.
We started with log u mass.
We have two copies
of log u over 2.
That's the same total mass.
So how many recursions do we do?
Well we do do log
log u recursions.
The total number of leaves in
that recursion tree is log u.
Each of them, we pay constant.
So this is log u, not log log u.
To get log log u, we need
to change this 2 into a 1.
We can only afford
one recursive call.
If we have two recursive calls,
we get logarithmic performance.
If we have three recursive
calls, it's even worse.
Here, I would definitely
use the Master method.
It's less obvious.
In this case, we get log u
to the log base 2 of 3 power,
which is log u to the 1.6 or
so, so both worse than log n.
This is strictly
worse than log n.
This is maybe just a little
bit worse than log n,
depending on how u relates to n.
OK, so we're not there yet.
But we're on the right track.
We have the right
kind of structure.
We have a problem of size u.
We split it up into square root
of u sub problems of size u.
From a data structures
perspective,
this the first time we're
using divide and conquer
for data structures.
It's a little different
from algorithms.
So that's how the data
structure is being laid out.
But now we're worried about
the algorithms on those data
structures.
Those, we can only afford t
of u equals 1 times [? t of ?]
squared of u plus order 1.
Then we get log log u.
So, here we have
two recursive calls.
Somehow we have
to have only one.
Let's start by fixing insert.
Insert?
No.
Let's start by fixing successor.
I think that will
be more intuitive.
Let's look at successor.
Because successor
is almost there.
A lot of the time, it's just
going to make this call,
and we're happy.
The bad cases is when we need
that make both of these calls.
Then there's three
total, very bad.
How could I get
rid of this call?
I was being all clever,
that the minimum element is
the successor of
negative infinity.
But that's actually
not the right idea.
Yeah.
[? AUDIENCE: Catching ?] the
minimum element in cluster i.
PROFESSOR: Store the minimum
element of cluster i.
Yeah.
In general, for every structure
v, let's store the minimum.
Why not?
We know how to
augment structures.
Here in 006, you
took an AVL tree,
and you augment node to store
the sub-tree size of the node.
In this case, we're doing a
similar kind of augmentation.
Just for every structure, keep
track of what the minimum is.
So that will be
idea number four.
I'm going to add something here.
But for now, let's
store the minimums.
So to do an insert into
to structure v, item x,
first thing we'll do
is just say, well,
if x is-- let's see if
it's the new minimum.
Maybe x is smaller
than v dot min.
If that's the case, let's
just set v dot min to x.
OK?
And then, the rest is
the same, same insertion
algorithm as over here,
these two recursive calls.
I just spent constant
additional time.
And now every structure
knows it's minimum.
Again, ignore delete for now.
That's trickier.
OK, now every structure
knows its minimum,
which means we can replace
this call with just v dot
cluster i dot min.
One down.
OK, so if we look at
successor, of v comma x.
I'm going to replace the last
line, or next to last line
with j equals v
cluster i dot min.
So now, we're down
to log u performance.
We only have, at most,
two recursive calls.
So that's partial progress.
But we need another idea to
get rid of the second one.
And the intuition here is that
really, only one of these call
should matter.
OK, let's draw the big picture.
Here's what the recursive
thing looks like.
We've got v dot summary.
Then we've got a
cluster 0, cluster 1,
cluster square
root of u minus 1.
Each of those is a
recursive structure.
And we're also just storing
the min over here as a copy.
So when I do a query
for, I don't know,
the successor of this guy,
there's kind of two cases.
One situation is that I
find the successor somewhere
in this interval.
In that case, I'm happy.
Because I just need
this one recursive call.
OK, the other case
is that I don't
find what I'm looking for here.
Then I have to do a
successor up here.
And then I'm done.
Then I can teleport into
whatever cluster it is.
And I've stored the min by now.
So that's constant time to
jump into the right spot
in the cluster.
So either I find what
I'm looking for here,
or I find what I'm
looking for here.
What would be
really nice is if I
could tell ahead of time
which one is going to succeed.
Because then, if I know this
is not going to find anything,
I might as well just
go immediately up here,
and look at the successor
in the summary structure.
If I know I'm going to
find something here,
I'll just do the successor here.
And I'm done.
If I could just
get away with one
or the other of these calls,
not both, I'd be very happy.
How could I tell that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Store the max.
PROFESSOR: Store the max.
Store the min and the max.
Why not?
OK, I just need a
similar line here.
If x is bigger than v
dot max, change the max.
So now, I've augmented
my data structure
to have the min and
max at every level.
And what's going on here
is, I won't find an answer
if I am greater than
or equal to the maximum
within this cluster.
That's how I tell.
If I'm equal to the max,
or if I'm beyond the max,
if all the items are over here,
the max will be to my left.
And then I know I will
fail within the cluster.
So I might as well just go up
to summary and do it there.
On the other hand, if
I'm less than the max,
then I'm guaranteed I will
find something in this cluster.
And so I can just
search in there.
So all I need to
do-- I'll probably
have to rewrite this slightly.
If x is-- not x, close.
I'm going to mimic this
code a little bit, at least
the first line is going
to be i equals high of x.
And now, that's the
cluster I'm starting in.
And I want to look at the
maximum of that cluster.
So I'm looking at v
dot cluster i dot max.
And I want to know,
is x before that?
Now within that cluster,
x is known as low of x.
So I compare low of x to
cluster i's maximum element.
If we're strictly to
the left, then there
is a successor guaranteed
within that substructure.
And so, I should do this line.
I wish I could copy paste.
But I will copy by hand.
Successor within v dot
cluster i, of low of x.
OK, then I've found the
item I'm looking for.
Else, I'm beyond the max, I
know this is the wrong cluster.
And so I should immediately
do these two lines, well,
except I've made the
second line use the min.
So it will only be one recursive
call, followed by a min.
OK, so this is going to be i
equals the successor within v
dot summary of high of x.
And then j is that
line successor
within-- oh, sorry--
the line that I
used to have here, which
is going to be v cluster i
dot min.
OK, and then, in both
cases, I return index of ij.
OK, so we're doing essentially
the same logic as over here.
Although I've replaced
the step with the min,
to get rid of that
recursive call.
But I'm really only doing
one or the other of these,
using max to distinguish.
If I'm left of the
max, I do the successor
within cluster high of x.
If I'm right of the max,
then I do the successor
immediately in
summary structure.
Because I know this won't
find anything useful.
And then I find the min within
that non-empty structure.
And in both cases, ij is
the element I'm looking for.
I put it back
together with index.
Clear?
What's the running
time of successor now?
Log log u.
Awesome.
We've finished successor.
Sadly, we have not
finished insert.
Insert still takes log u time.
But, b progress.
Maybe your routing table
doesn't change that often,
so you can afford to pay
some extra time for insert,
as long as you can route
packets really fast,
as long as you can find
where something belongs,
the successor in log log u time.
But for kicks, let's do
insert in log log u as well.
This is going to
be a little harder,
or I would say a
more surprising idea.
This may be--
I don't have a great
intuition for this step.
I'm thinking.
But again, most of the time,
this should be fine, right?
Most of the time, we insert into
cluster high of x, low of x,
and we're done.
As long as there is something
already in that cluster,
we don't need to update
the summary structure.
As long as high of x has already
been inserted into the summary
structure, we can get away
with just this first step.
The tricky part is detecting.
How would we know?
Well, that's not enough
just to detect it.
If high of x is not
in v dot summary,
we have to do this insert.
We can't get away with it.
But that's kind of rare.
That only happens
the very first time
you insert into that cluster.
Every subsequent time, it's
going to be really cheap.
We just have to do this.
It's easy enough to keep track
of whether a cluster is empty.
For example, we're
storing the min.
We can say v dot min is
none, special value, whenever
the structure v is empty.
But we still have this problem,
that the first time we insert
into a cluster, it's expensive.
Because we have to do this.
And we have to do this.
How could we avoid, in the
case where a cluster is empty--
remember, an overall
structure looks like this.
We can tell that it's empty
by saying min equals none,
let's say.
What could I do?
Sorry, there's also a max now.
What could I do to
speed up inserting
into an empty cluster?
Because I'm first
going to have to insert
into the empty cluster.
Then I'm going to have to
answer into the summary.
I can't get away from this.
So I'd like this to become
cheap, in the special case when
this cluster is empty.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Lazy propogation.
PROFESSOR: Lazy propagation--
you want to elaborate?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We mark the place we
want to insert in.
And then we will take it down
whenever we [? insert ?] there.
PROFESSOR: Good.
So when I insert into
an empty structure,
I'm just going to have a little
lazy field, or something.
And I'll put the item in there.
And then the next
time I insert into it,
maybe I'll carry it
down a little bit.
That actually works.
And that was the original
van Emde Boas structure,
[? I ?] [? learned ?]
[? recently. ?]
So that works.
But it's a little more
complicated than the solution
I have in mind.
So I'm going to unify that lazy
field with the minimum field.
Say, when I insert
into a structure,
if there's nothing
here, I'm just
going to put the item
there, and not recurse.
I just am not going to store
the minimum item recursively.
Definitely frisbee.
So that's the last
idea, pretty much.
Idea number five is, don't
store the min recursively.
This is effectively
equivalent to lazy.
But we're actually
just never going
to get around to
moving this guy down.
Just leave it there.
First, if the min field is
blank, store the item there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean
by moving the guy down?
PROFESSOR: Don't worry
about moving the guy down.
We're not going to do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But in
general, moving down
means, when I want
to insert an item,
I have to move it down
into its sub cluster.
So I want to insert
x into the cluster,
high of x with low of
x, that recursive call.
That's moving it down.
I'm not going to do that.
If the structure
is empty, I'm going
to set v dot min equal
to x, and then stop.
Let me illustrate with
some code, maybe over here.
Here's what I mean.
If v dot min is special
none value-- use
Python notation here--
then I'm just going
to set v dot min equal to x.
I should also set v
dot max equal to x.
Because I want to keep
track of the maximum.
And then, stop.
Return.
That's all I will
do for inserting
into an empty structure, is
stick it in the max field.
OK, this may seem
like a minor change.
But it's going to
make this cheap.
So the rest of the algorithm
is going to be pretty similar.
There's a couple
annoying special cases,
which is, we have to
keep the min up to date.
And we have to keep the
max up to date, in general.
This one is easy.
We just set v dot
max equal to x.
Because we're not doing
anything fancy with max.
Min is a little special.
Because if we're
inserting an item smaller
than the current minimum, then
really x belongs in the slot.
And then whatever
was in here needs
to be recursively inserted.
OK, so I'm going to say
swap x with v dot min.
So I'm going to put x
into the v dot min slot.
And I'm going to pull out
whatever item was in there
and call it x now.
And now my remaining
goal is to insert x
into the rest of the structure.
There's only one item that
gets this freedom of not
being recursively stored.
And it's always going
to be the minimum one.
So this way, the new
value x goes there.
Whatever it used to be there now
has to be recursively inserted.
Because every item
except the minimum,
we're going to
recursively insert.
So the rest is
pretty much the same.
But we're going to,
instead of always inserting
into the summary
structure, we're
going to see whether
it's necessary.
Because we know how to do that.
We just look at a
cluster high of x.
And we see, is it empty?
Cluster high of x-- and empty
means its minimum is none.
So we're going to--
in fact, the next line
after this one is going
to be insert v cluster
high of x, comma low of x.
All right, that's this line.
We're always going to do that.
And in the special case,
where there was not previously
nothing in v cluster
high of x, we
need to update the
summary structure.
And we do that with this line.
So I'm going to insert into
v dot summary high of x.
But I'm only doing that in
the case when I need to.
If it was already non-empty, I
know this has already happened.
So I don't need to bother
with that insertion.
OK, this is a weird algorithm.
Because it doesn't
look much better.
In the worst case, we're doing
two recursive calls to insert.
But I claim this runs
in log log u time.
Why?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because when we
update the v dot summary,
we [? just ?] [? have the ?]
[? first ?] [? line. ?]
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
In the case when I have to
do this summary insertion,
I know this guy was empty.
Cluster high of x was empty.
So this call is just going
to do these two lines.
Because I optimized
the case of empty--
when a structure is empty,
I spend constant time,
no recursive calls.
That means in the case when
cluster high of x is empty,
and I have to pay to insert
into the summary structure,
I know my second call is
going to be free, only
take constant time.
So either I do this, in which
case this takes constant time,
or I don't do this, in which
case I make one recursive call.
In both cases, I really am
only making one recursive call.
OK, so this runs in log log u.
Because I get the t of u
equals 1 times square root
of t of u plus
order 1 recurrence.
All the work I'm doing
here is constant time,
other than the recursive calls.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So when we
insert the first time,
we don't update v dot summary?
PROFESSOR: When I insert into
a completely empty structure,
we don't update summary at all.
That's right.
We just store it in the
min, and we're done.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So then, if you were to
[? call ?] the successor,
and you--
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
The successor algorithm
is currently incorrect.
Thank you.
Here's some frisbees for that
question and the last answer.
Yeah.
This code is now slightly wrong.
Because sometimes I'm storing
elements in v dot min.
And successor is just
completely ignoring them.
So it's not going
to find those items.
Luckily, it's a very simple fix.
Out of room, but please
insert right in here.
If x is less v dot
min, return v dot min.
That's all we need to do.
The min is special.
Because we're not
storing it recursively.
And so, we can't rely on all
of our recursive structures.
We can't rely on cluster i.
We can't rely on summary, on
reporting about v dot min.
v dot min is just a
special item sitting there.
It's represented nowhere else.
But we can check.
Because it's the
minimum element,
and we're looking
for successors,
it's really easy to
check for whether it's
the item we're looking for.
Because it's the smallest one.
If we're smaller than it, then
that's clearly the successor.
OK, so in that case, we
just spent constant time.
So it actually speeds up some
situations for successor.
We're not exploiting that here.
It doesn't help much
in the worst case.
But now, it should be correct.
Hopefully, you're happy.
Any other questions?
So at this point, we have what
I will call a van Emde Boas.
This last version-- we can do
insert and successor in log
log u time.
Yeah, sorry.
I modified the wrong
successor algorithm, didn't I?
I meant to modify this one.
This is the fast one.
So please put that code here.
That's the log log u
version of successor.
We just added this
constant time check.
And now this runs
in log log u time.
The key idea here was
if we store the max,
then we know which of the two
recursive calls we need to do.
If we store the min,
this doesn't end up
being a recursive call.
So that's very clean.
With insert, we needed this
trickier idea that the min,
we're not even going to
recursively represent.
We'll just keep it there.
That requires this extra
little check for successor.
But it allows us to
do insert cheaply
in all cases-- cheap meaning
only one recursive call.
Either we need to update
the summary structure,
in which case that
thing was empty,
and so we can think
of that cluster--
so we have this special
case of inserting
into an empty cluster,
which is super cheap,
or most of the time, you imagine
that the cluster was already
non-empty.
And so we don't need to
update the summary structure.
And then we just
do this recursion.
So in all cases,
everything is cheap.
Now the one thing I've
been avoiding is delete.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] If x
is greater than [? v ?] max,
[? we ?] [? swap ?] [? x ?]
[? with ?] [? v ?] [? max? ?]
PROFESSOR: So if x is
greater than v max,
I'm just going to update v max.
V max is stored recursively.
We're not doing anything
fancy with v max.
And we had, at some
point, a similar line.
So this is just updating v max.
Yeah, nothing special there.
In your problem set, you'll look
at a more symmetric version,
where you don't recursively
store min and max.
It works about the same.
But in some ways, the
code is actually prettier.
So you'll get to do that.
Other questions?
All right.
So, delete.
We have insert and successor.
And through all these
steps, it would actually
be very hard to do delete.
It turns out, at this
point, delete is no problem.
So let me give you
some delete codes.
It's a little bit long.
Maybe I'll start with
a high level picture,
sort of the main cases.
Deleting the min is a little bit
special, as you might imagine.
That element is different
from every other element.
So if x equals min, we're
going to do something else.
But let me specify that later.
Let's get to the bulk
of the code, which
is we're going to delete low
of x from cluster high of x.
That's the obvious
recursion to do.
This is essentially the
reverse of insert over here.
The first thing we
do is undo this.
In all cases, insert
was doing that.
So in all cases,
delete has to do
that, other than the
special case of the min.
And then, we need to
do the inverse of this.
So if that was the
last item, then we
need to delete from
the summary structure.
So it's actually
pretty symmetric,
other than the tiny details.
So after we delete, we can
check, is that structure empty.
Because then, the
min would equal none.
OK.
If that's the case, we delete
from the summary structure.
OK.
Cool.
And there is a bit
of a special case
at the end, which is when we
deleted the maximum element.
OK, so I need to fill these in.
And it's important that
these are filled in right.
Because in some
situations here, we
are making two recursive calls.
But again, we'd like it to
be, when we do both calls,
we want one of them to be cheap.
Now this one's
hard to make cheap.
So when we delete from
the summary structure,
we want this to delete to
have taken only constant time,
no recursions.
And that's going to
correspond to this case.
Because if we made
the cluster empty,
that means we deleted
the last item.
What's the last item?
Has to be v dot min.
If you have a size
1 structure, it's
always because that
item is in v dot min,
everything else is empty.
So that's the case of
deleting v dot min.
So we want this case to
take constant time when it's
the last item we're deleting.
So let's fill that in a little.
Let's see if I can fit it in.
This is code that
turns out to work
in this if x equals v dot min.
It's a little bit subtle.
But the key thing to check
here is, we want to know,
is this the last item.
And one way to do that is to
look at the summary structure,
and say, do you have
any non-empty clusters?
If you don't have any
non-empty clusters,
that means your min is none.
And that means, the only thing
keeping the structure non-empty
is the minimum element.
That's stored in v dot min.
So in that case, that's
the one situation
when v dot min becomes none.
We never set v dot min equals
none in the other algorithms.
Because initially
everything is none.
But when we're inserting,
we never empty a structure.
Now we're doing delete.
This is the one
situation when v dot
min becomes none from scratch.
In that case, no
recursive calls.
So that means this
algorithm is efficient.
Because if I had to delete
from the summary structure,
this only had a single item,
which is this situation.
Then I just set v dot
min equals to none.
And I'm done.
So this will, overall,
run in log log u time.
Now, it could be we're
deleting the min,
but it was not the only item.
So that's this situation.
In that situation,
we want to find out
what the min actually is.
Right?
We just deleted the min.
We want to put
something in v dot min.
We can't set it to none.
Because that indicates the
whole structure is empty.
So we have to recursively rip
out the new minimum out item.
Because it should not be
recursively stored anymore.
And then we're going to
stick it into v dot min.
So now, finding minimum items
is actually pretty easy.
We just looked at the
first non-empty structure.
And we looked at
the-- I think I'm
missing-- oh, v dot
cluster i min, I guess,
closed parenthesis.
That is the minimum item
in the first cluster.
So I want to
recursively delete it.
So I'm setting x to that thing.
And then I'm going to do
all this code, which will
delete x from that structure.
And then-- I mean, I'm
doing it all right here.
But then, I'm going to set
v dot min to be that value.
So then v dot min
has a new value.
Because I deleted the old one.
And it's no longer
recursively stored.
I don't want two copies
of x floating around.
So that's why I do, even in this
if case, I do all these steps.
Cool?
You can see delete--
is that a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, why did
I set v dot max to none?
AUDIENCE: Because
[? that's the ?] all
[? these ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? x ?] equals v dot max,
the last time.
AUDIENCE: [? Do you ?]
[? find v dot max? ?]
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
I'm not done yet.
I haven't specified
what to do here.
OK, you really want to know?
OK.
Let's go somewhere else.
I have enough room, I think.
Eh, maybe I can squeeze it in.
It's going to be super compact.
So, when x equals v dot
max, there are two cases.
So max is a little different.
We just need to
keep it up to date.
So it's not that hard.
We don't have to do
any recursive magic.
Well, I need another line.
Sorry.
Let me go up to the other board.
OK, I think that's the
complete delete code.
You asked for it.
You've got it.
So, at this point,
we have just deleted
the max, which means we
need to find, basically,
the predecessor of x.
But we can't afford
a recursive call.
I mean, that's OK.
It's just, we're trying to
find the max in what remains.
Imagine v dot max is just wrong.
So we've got to set
it from scratch.
It's not that hard to do.
Basically, we want to take
the last non-empty structure.
That would v dot
summary dot max,
and then find the last
item in that cluster.
OK, so cluster i is the
last one for v dot summary.
And then we look v dot
cluster of i dot max.
And we combine it with i.
That gives us the name of
that item in the last cluster,
the last non-empty cluster.
But there's a
special case, which
is maybe this returns none.
Maybe there actually is
nothing in v dot summary.
That means we just deleted
the last item, I guess.
Or there's only one left.
We deleted the
next to last time.
Now there's only one item
left, namely v dot min.
So we set v dot max
equal to v dot min.
So that's a special case.
But most the time,
you're just doing
a couple dot max's,
and you're done.
So that's how you
maintain the maxes,
even when you're deleting.
And unless I made an error,
I think all these algorithms
work together.
You're going to insert,
delete, and successor.
And symmetrically, you can
do predecessor in log log u
time per operation, super fast.
Let me tell you a
couple other things.
One is, there's a
matching lower bound.
Log log-- maybe
you wonder, can I
get log log log time, log log
log log time, or whatever?
No.
In most reasonable
choices of parameters--
it's a little bit more
complicated than this--
but for most of the time
that you care about,
log log u is the right answer.
This was proved in 2007.
So it took us decades
to really understand.
It's by a former MIT student.
So I'll give you some
range where it holds,
which will raise another issue.
But, OK.
So this range is the range
I talked about before.
This is when log log
u equals log log n.
So that's kind of the case where
you care about applying it.
If log log u is more like log
n, it's not so interesting.
But as long as u is
not too big, this
is a little bit bigger
than polynomial n.
Then this is the right answer.
Now technically, you
need another assumption,
which is the space of
your data structure
is not to super linear.
Now this is a little awkward.
Because the space of
this data show structure
is actually order u, not n.
So the last issue is space.
Space is order u.
Let me go back to this
binary tree picture.
So we had the idea
of, well, there's
all these bits at the bottom.
We're building a big
binary tree above those.
The leaves are the actual data.
And then we're summarizing,
by for every node,
we're writing the or of
the two nodes below it,
which is summarizing whether
that thing is non-empty.
What van Emde Boas is
doing-- so first of all,
you see that the total number of
nodes in this tree is order u.
Because there's u leaves.
The total size of a
binary tree with u leaves
is order u, 2u minus 1, right?
And you can kind of see what
van Emde Boas is doing here.
First, it's thinking
about the middle level.
Now it's not directly
looking at these bits.
It says, hey look,
I know my item,
the thing I'm doing a successor
of, let's say, is three.
I want to know the
successor of this position.
First, I want to check, should
I recurse in this block,
or should I recurse
in the summary
block-- which I didn't draw.
But it's the part of the
tree that would be up here.
And that's exactly what
we're doing with successor.
Should we recursively
look within cluster i?
Or should we look within
the summary structure?
We only do one or the other.
And that's the sense in
which we are binary searching
on the levels of this tree.
Either we will spend all of
our work recursively looking
for the successor within
the summary structure, which
is like finding the next 1 bit
in this row, the middle row,
or we will spend all of our
time doing successor in here.
And we can do that.
Because we have
the max augmented.
OK, but that's the
sense in which, kind of,
you are binary searching
in the levels of this tree.
So that's that early
intuition for van Emde Boas
is kind of what we're doing.
The trouble is, to store that
tree takes order u space.
We'd really like to
spend order n space.
And I have four minutes.
So you'll see part of
the answer to this.
My poor microphone.
Let me give you an idea of
how to fix the space bound.
Let's erase some algorithms.
The main idea here is only
store non-empty clusters,
pretty simple idea.
We want to spend space
only for the present items,
not for the absent ones.
So don't store the absent ones.
In particular, we're
doing all this work around
when clusters are
empty, in which case
we can see that just by
looking at the min item,
or when they're non-empty.
So let's just store
the non-empty ones.
That will get you down to
almost order n space, not quite,
but close.
To do this, v dot cluster
is no longer an array.
Just make it a hash table,
a dictionary in Python.
So v dot cluster--
we were always
doing v dot cluster of i.
Just make that into dictionary
instead of an array.
And you save most of the space.
You only have to store
the non-empty items.
And you should know from
006, hash table is constant
expected.
We'll prove that formally
in lecture eight, I think.
But for now, take
hashing as given.
Everything we did before is
essentially the same cost,
but an expectation,
no longer worst case.
But now the space goes way down.
Because if you look at an
item, when you insert an item,
it sort of goes to log
log u different places,
in the worst case.
But, yeah.
We end up with n log log u
space, which is pretty good,
almost linear space.
It's a little tricky to
see why you get log log u.
But I guess if you look
at the insert algorithm,
even though we had two recursive
calls in the worst case.
One of them was free.
When we do both of
them, we insert here.
This one happens to be free.
Because it was empty.
But we still pay for it.
We set v dot min equal to x.
And so that structure went
from empty to non-empty.
So this costs 1.
And then we recursively
call insert v dot summary
on high of x.
So we might, when we insert
one item x, if lots of things
were empty, actually log log
u structures become non-empty,
and that's why you pay log log
u for each item you insert.
It's kind of annoying.
There is a fix,
which is in my notes.
You can read it, for reducing
this further to order n.
But, OK, I have 30
seconds to explain it.
The idea is-- you're not
responsible for knowing it.
This is just in
case you're curious.
The idea is, instead of
going all the way down
in the recursion,
at the very bottom,
you say, well,
normally if you stop
the recursion when
you have u equals
1, just stop the recursion
when n is very small,
like log log u.
When I'm only storing
log log u items,
put them in a linked list.
I don't care.
You can do whatever you
want on log log u items
in log log u time.
It's just a tiny tweak.
But it turns out, it gets rid
of that log u in the space.
So it's a little bit messier.
And I don't know if you'd
want to implement it that way.
But you can reduce
to linear space.
And that's van Emde Boas.